[Music]
hi everybody
uh welcome to uh our our lovely session
here uh
very excited to talk to you all uh about
probably every buzzword in the industry
we could possibly jam into one session
hybrid machine learning devops
kubernetes like just tensorflow take
your pick like we tried to fit it all in
because bingo
we're inclusionists here like we like to
include everything
everybody everything every solution all
of it all at once so
uh we'll kick things off we'd like to
just introduce ourselves so you kind of
uh
know who we are and and what we're doing
here um so my name is rob schmidt
i am a customer engineering manager for
google cloud based out of
chicago i primarily work with our large
retail customers to
help them adopt the cloud and transform
their businesses and over to my left
here is
i'm ryan mcguire i'm a cto of augmented
intelligence for a
fortune 500 digital transformation
consulting company out of chicago uh
we're a partner with uh google so happy
to be here
let rob take the stage all right um so
let's let's start with a little bit of
definition of kind of what we're
we're doing so what is the edge like it
it's a lot of things it can kind of be
anything you want to define it as but
for
for our purposes we're really talking
about areas of constrained compute
where you have potentially a limited
amount of resources in which you can
execute
your model um so you know in data
centers oftentimes people are going to
be running just
straight tensorflow in in iot devices
that sort of change things with mobile
there's lots of different
uh techniques and things we can use
depending on where we're going but the
fact of the matter is
is that machine learning models are
going to be running ev everywhere
on all of these surfaces very soon so we
need to start thinking about
how we start to uh how we start to
transform these these devices and
and bring uh the services to them and we
need to do that for
for for a number of reasons right um
you know obviously with google cloud we
have lots of really awesome vision apis
that are very easy to adopt
and give you a fair amount of thing but
there's there that comes with a cost
uh so for latency reasons you might not
be you're going to have a round-trip
time
uh trying to get anything up to those
apis or back uh bandwidth is also an
issue when you have
not a lot of uh if you're on a mobile
network or you are
in an area where you don't have a good
connectivity back to
back to the cloud privacy reasons
there's reasons to do things on devices
and not ship things up to the cloud
particularly with things like
for example like very very sensitive
healthcare data or sensor data or things
that are very private
connectivity as we sort of alluded to is
always going to be an issue especially
in iot
scenarios and obviously execution cost
a lot of times it can be it can be quite
expensive to hurl a lot
of data and a lot of of compute up in
the cloud
to get this kind of stuff
but the cloud still has a role and we
need to think about how we leverage the
cloud for what it's good for
and how we leverage the devices uh for
what they
are really good for um so to that to
that end obviously in the cloud you have
the the computing power obviously we've
got gpus and tpus
available that you can uh bolt on and
use to accelerate your
machine learning processes and get
things done faster and that leads right
into the velocity
so you're able to move and iterate
quickly by using things like cloud ml
engine and
and other tools like that at the
elasticity you scale up when you train
and when you're done you turn it all off
so you're not uh
using uh having to have deadweight
resources just sitting out there
data storage is really another area
where the cloud makes a lot of sense
because you have to centralize and
aggregate a lot of this data
in order to train your models and
obviously training cost is really good
if we use things like preemptable vms uh
and other things like and other than the
elasticity
uh that we're then able to minimize a
lot of that stuff
so there's really three considerations
that we need to think about
uh when we're starting to think about uh
running a machine learning model at the
edge
uh one is the model and binary size um
obviously
a lot of these models are going to be
running in memory so if you don't have a
lot of memory
that's something we need to control for
and make sure we get that as small as
possible so that
it's able to run in those in those
scenarios obviously that also has an
impact to
the speed at which it's able to run if
you're using a lot of the memory already
you're not able to push transactions
through it as fast and it also
can impact application performance and
you know as we look at that
you know slow performance in an app
application is a killer uh people will
not tolerate that these days
uh and and you know you have to start
thinking about your device itself and
threading so
uh by default tensorflow sets that to
the default number of cores on the
device but we need to
understand that hardware profile so we
can decide do we need more
do we need to utilize more cores uh do
we need to utilize more threads
uh in order to move forward
so that's all great like we all
understand kind of the problem space
um but how do we actually go there and
there's really four phases that you need
we need to think about
and there's a lot of constraints and
considerations that we need to take into
account at each one of these phases
in order to get our model out so first
we're going to talk about building the
model um obviously
we're primarily talking about tensorflow
here and the reason we're talking about
tensorflow
is because it's a very flexible uh
execution environment and training
environment for for machine learning
so we're able to actually utilize it to
go straight from the cloud to the edge
uh with very little uh change
to the actual machinery that we're
running on um
but when we when we can start to
consider the problem and what we're
doing
uh we need to understand where we're
going to be putting this model
at the beginning choices you make at
this stage of the game have
a very severe downstream impact if
you're not considering them so
we want to understand where we're going
to be running this model is it going to
be running on a raspberry pi
in a closet is it going to be running
directly on a piece of machinery
you know what what kind of hardware
environment what are the latency
requirements of this particular model
that we're going to be trying to run
um and understand that like as we make
those choices
uh we're going to be having we're going
to be constrained
in several different ways so whether
it's the whether
it's the ram or the compute performance
whether it's the size of the model or
the choice of the model that we're going
to use or build
um you know we need to understand at
that point what we're going to be doing
so that we can choose the right model
and build the right model
so components at this point like there's
a lot of different things that we use
obviously tensorflow i talked about but
uh having jupiter and ipython notebook
so your your
team of engineers and data scientists
can iterate quickly and share the data
and get everything moving quickly
uh is important um kubeflow if you're if
you're if you're in on kubernetes
kubeflow is another great pattern uh
that people are starting to adopt
uh because it kind of homogenizes a lot
of that uh like
training infrastructure and ipython
notebooks and sharing and all that stuff
obviously the thing like the big glaring
hole that everybody needs to think about
is training data
and testing data uh if you don't have
enough data there are ways around that
um
but obviously we need to have good
quality data so that we're able to
actually build
this model and get good performance out
of it um but but in in some cases where
you don't have good data or maybe it's
not particularly good you can start with
a pre-trained model from tf hub
pull that down and then you can do a
little bit of transfer learning on it
to accelerate yourself and not maybe be
constrained by as much data as
you may need so when we look at the
actual training of the model
first we have to make sure we've got
enough data as i just said
another constraint that we need to think
about is how fast do we actually need to
do this training
how often are we changing the model how
often are we
looking at actually improving the model
so because that has
that has a an impact too if you are in
an iot use case
in manufacturing and you tell your plant
manager that you're going to have to
take a whole machine down for three
hours so you can update the sensor model
they're not going to be happy with you
that's that's money just flowing out the
door
another thing to think about at this
point is is what we call quantization
uh quantization is something that you
you package into the actual training
execution in tensorflow and what
quantization does
is it simply takes the graph so
tensorflow executes in floating point
by default but on an edge device or on a
a very constrained area where you don't
have a lot of gpus you don't have a lot
of
floating point operations that can be
really hard to run it's like really hard
for mobile phones to run uh
all that floating point stuff at the
moment um so what quantization does is
it takes all of it and flips it into
8-bit integer calculation now there's a
consequence to that
so you're going to get the performance
and you're going to get all a lot of
increase in boost
but your model is going to be less
accurate now
so when you quantize the model you also
have to make sure that you're
understanding
what that accuracy loss is going to be
and what you actually need to be
successful
obviously in a lot of various industries
there's going to be specialized hardware
as we're starting to see we announced
edge tpus and things like that so we're
starting to see some
some some changes to to how we're
actually building these things
and that's that's an important thing to
understand here because you have to know
what you're going to be running on so
that you can actually make sure that the
execution environment is good
and obviously one of the big risks to
training is always data bias
you know oftentimes we bias the data
unintentionally
we walk in with the best of intentions
and wind up doing it ourselves
because we're humans and we're biased so
understanding that you might not have
all the data or you might be excluding
certain kinds of data that have an
impact to your model is important as
well
so in this in this as we look at kind of
the architectural components that we
would use here
obviously cube flow can do it can be a
training and an execution engine you can
use that caught ml engine for
you know like the fully serverless style
of
training and execution is another good
component too and obviously using tpus
and gpus at this point are
really are really good because it's
gonna it's gonna start to shrink that
time down that you're gonna need
uh to to actually build uh this this
model out and get it trained and tested
so moving on to the the preparing the
model phase
so at this stage really what we're
trying to do is
uh understand that we've got we got to
understand what the performance
characteristics of the model are going
to be
a lot of a lot of ways things that we
can do are built into the tensorflow
libraries themselves but we want to make
sure that we understand
exactly what we're going to be doing
this model on and how it's going to
execute in the environment that we're
going to be running it in
so a couple of tools that we can use are
the tensorflow profiler this is a great
built-in tool that can give you actual
performance metrics based on
uh the graph that comes out of the
training session uh and then the other
thing that we start to look at at this
point
is the tf light benchmark library so
if you're in a mobile or in a uh like a
sort of an iot situation tensorflow lite
is probably the destination you're going
to wind up at
uh it it's built in it what it does is
it restricts
a number of heavyweight uh hardcore cpu
operations uh
from the from the model and it comes
with a a custom uh protocol buffer
uh that lets you execute in it's
specifically designed to be executed in
mobile environments
um and so what you do is after you
quantize your model you're able to run
this this converter called toco
and that's what turns it into the actual
tensorflow lite graph
that you can then take and execute a
couple other
things to consider at this point are
model encryption obviously a lot of
these models are running in memory
and it's not baked encryption is not
baked into tensorflow or tensorflow lite
but it is available to
to build uh there's there's a little
tutorial up on the tensorflow website
if you are concerned about people
scraping the memory and taking your
model and doing something else with it
so that's something that you also want
to consider at this point as well
at this point now we got to actually get
the model running and there's a number
of different ways we could we could
actually approach this situation
obviously we could run in containers we
could run natively on android or ios
package it right into our app
uh you know do we have edge tpus are we
using android iot
we could have kubeflow deployed to an
edge location like for example if you
have a
a fleet of of different service centers
with small data centers inside of them
like like you know three or four
nucs from intel uh you could deploy
kubeflow there and then you have a nice
really end-to-end service at that point
but you kind of need to take into
account um everything that you've got
rolling
in your data centers and where you're
going to be and make sure and think
about how often
at this point in time you're going to be
training that model right so if you
package everything into an app
and you retrain your model well guess
what now you got to push a new app out
to the app store
like people got to go and download it
and update it so there's often times you
need to think about like okay
like how am i going to do this so that
i'm giving my users the best experience
given the fact that i'm probably going
to be training the model more frequently
than i'm going to be updating the
application
because that's that's going to be a key
thing that happens here the thing about
machine learning is it doesn't really
stop
it has to keep going so with that i
would like to bring ryan back up on
stage to talk about uh the journey that
his team has gone through
um to trying to uh to execute a very
similar vision of the one we just talked
about
thanks rob um so we're going to talk a
little bit about
an example today um about cocoa
for those of you know coco coco was a
gorilla who learned sign language
actually coco was born here
in san francisco just down the road at
the zoo and over a period of time
she learned sign language was able to
communicate so we're going to use that
as a model today to demonstrate what rob
talked about
about some of those flows at solstice
you know our mission is to prove what
humanity is capable of
and what a better way to take machine
learning computer vision
neural networks and an experience to
kind of
help those in need to prove what
humanity is capable of
so we're going to walk through the slide
a little bit and talk about the steps
that rob talked about
first step being you know building your
model using the cloud and the power of
the cloud to do that
here we had a series of images
that we used to train the model to make
sure that we selected the right model
as robert talked about with the
deployment model of the edge
we want to give consideration to the
things that
we might not have thought through so
what operations could go through a
tensor light
conversion and how would we do that
should we use a
you know an object recognition that's
already trained or should we train
ourselves should we use
ssd should we use vgg um those types of
things so in this phase
we started to work out a lot of those
types of things using the power of the
cloud with google
compute engine to do those types of
things
really important in this space is to
have your training set and your test set
aligned up so i'll show a demo in a
little bit about using
a sparsely trained set we'll call her
coco jr
she only knows three letters and then
we'll show kind of a demo of
you know coco senior being trained on a
full set of data
you know different hand gestures
different colors left and right
and those types of things to have a more
rich and robust model
once you have that model uh and and
you've got it built you want to train it
you you want to set some validation
points
you know am i comfortable at 50 accuracy
do i need a 90
actuary how much coverage do i want um
so we'll talk a little bit about how we
did that there
and then like this whole quantities it's
a cool word right the edge quantized
this is like
where you now get to take the power of
the cloud and compact it
right a whole world in a teeny bitty b
space right so putting it out to the
edge so getting ready to do that
so we use quantization to do that
conversion down to
tensorflow lite and then we use
traditional means of ci cd pipelines
so we're constantly training the model
in the cloud with new imagery and data
that we have
and we have a ci cd pipeline that we'll
demonstrate in the application
we're able to make the switch between
coco jr and coco senior
in in near real time which is really
important to the user experience
um does that make sense yeah who wants
to see coco
before we do i want to talk a little bit
about the the
the differences here so you can see the
top track we have coco jr
who's only trained on a and b with a
with a minimum set of observations
that model is available in a version in
our continuous integration environment
where we can pull that down from our
storage bucket
on the bottom we've taken more of a
robust approach using the power of
auto ml engine you know imagery and data
to really train coco senior to know
the the soup to knots alphabet and
interfacing with the application so
with that said i'm going to bring up
coco jr if you could switch
over the displays um so here we have uh
an android app uh displayed here on
screen
um image image recognition camera's on
um you can see the image process over
here which which will do motion
detection
uh once we put up a hand signal but
as demos go let's see if she's working
ah she worked she knows a
yay however
if we go to h which is this signal
no letter detected uh but to prove out
that she knows b we can go ahead and put
up
b signal so she knows b but she's only
61 percent
certain that it's a b um so now what
we're going to do is we're going to pull
down
through the cicd pipeline that we have
available with coco senior trained
so we've got these these buttons that
basically toggle versions
of the model back and forth inside of
the application
so that we get the latest and greatest
so we're going to go ahead and
update here to coco senior and as you
see you can see coco senior is now
taking over but nothing's really changed
from the experience
so we can go ahead
okay so she knows a but let's see if she
knows
h o
so you can see that the power of having
data
in a different training set brings you
to the next level of what you're capable
of doing
i could show you right hand signals we
could have a small children's hand
a woman's hand a man's hand all these
are different signals into your
environment when you're thinking about
the model that you're creating so your
test inputs your data set
are very important but let's envision
for a second that
we took this to the next level and
you know we didn't have that training
set you could have the power
of a continuous learning cycle with coco
that could capture go into training mode
and now it's capturing images and you're
allowing your user population
to feed back into that loop creating
your training set
you're not going to run that locally at
the edge you want that information to go
back
up into the cloud and we'll go to talk
about it a bit in a second
i'm going to call rob back up here if we
could switch back screen
oh i'm going to click this so rob is
this how it
works in the real world today with with
coco uh yeah
but it's truly that's only half the
story
um as we think about this like like at
this point it's like congratulations
we've deployed a model like yay
everybody's excited but there's so much
more we actually have to do at this
point and as ryan alluded to
we've got to get feedback from the users
we've got to aggregate the data we've
got to organize the data
we've got to update the model we got to
keep going through this cycle onward and
onward and onward
um so you know a couple of things that i
really liked about the approach that
that solstice took in this model was
they
they sort of decoupled the app execution
from the actual model graph which is
pretty slick
so they can we're able to deploy that
out to a cdn basically
and have have it going back and forth
right there without having to update the
app itself
so putting that logic into the
application was pretty was was it was
pretty smooth i think that's a good
pattern that you're going to start to
see people adopt
uh going forward yeah well and i think
it's a really important thing you talked
about
something that all of us that are
intimately familiar with right the
software engineering practices
you know that cycle is never done you
never finish an application you're
always constantly grooming it
so at solsys we've adopted an approach
called continuous learning which is a
mix of
agile principles reinforced learning
supervised learning
which we take it through a cycle very
much like we talked about today and then
that prior slide going from selecting
your model and experimenting
training your model the initial flow of
that evaluating what are your criteria
for getting it out the door
and going through each one of these
steps but it's evergreen it's it's never
stopping we're using
modern software engineering principles
cicd
process you know maybe some a b testing
in here
to put our model out into production and
get our feedback so you can envision an
nlp chat bot that is you know making a
recommendation
uh for a particular purchase order and
asking for validation from the end user
was that right
and then that flowing back into the
process so that we can elevate the
the capability of our machine learning
models in a commercialization to go from
just reasoning uh for a human to
actually helping make decisions
so one of the things that we'd like to
do is just kind of walk through
between google and solstice put together
this model of like what an ideal state
architecture is
and how that might fit into a model to
give you guys the tools
as you walk away from this conference
this meeting
and you think about how you're going to
take forward what you've learned here
today
and apply it to to your business so
we'll start with
the the experiment and train section
here um
using gcp we've we've lined up the
ability to use bigquery
uh bigtable and other cloud storage as
kind of that
foundation data layer and we'll talk
about it later is how
um that that true feedback data flows
into it
but you can see you've got your dev
cluster and your prod models living side
by side
uh creating that trained model that's
constantly
evaluating new sets of data and new
points of data inside of that anything
to add there rob
yeah i think it's it's a it's an
important piece that you need to have
uh that i think people don't think about
as they're going through this is is
curating your data and making sure that
you have
a consistent environment for your teams
to actually build an experiment with
these models on
uh and and making sure that you're doing
that in in a safe way making sure that
everybody has access to what they need
uh making sure you're respecting user
privacy and all the other concerns that
we have in software development
um and then you give them the
opportunity to just take go right from
that spot to
cloud machine learning and do the actual
training execution
so you're basically unconstraining them
now from resource
uh usage and and that's i think the
ideal states it's going to let people
move quickly
and actually start to execute these
these patterns uh
rapidly yeah no i think that's great and
and this kind of blueprint gives uh
well where do i start and and when do i
end and how do i start it again
right and so it's a really good model to
it so stepping out of that it's into the
evaluation the deploy stage
you can take this you know for what it
is at this level or you can even go
further detail so
put in whatever continuous integration
cicd tool
of your choice in this spot again using
that cube flow to deploy to the edge
you know containerizing packaging doing
the tf light using spinnaker to get it
to
the edge of ice but inside of this you
could get more sophisticated say you had
a confusion matrix
that you wanted you know uh 90 along
your confusion matrix you want your roc
curve to be these types of things
in your continuous integration
environment like you do today with your
web applications
you could set a threshold for coverage
right these models are set to have these
types of facilities to be able to
measure
the validation of it your deployment
here doesn't necessarily have to overlay
the production
uh model that's there you could put that
behind an a b testing platform
say 80 of your routes are going you know
to
the old model while 20 are going to the
new so you can really measure the value
of those types of things
this is the type of space where we're
taking the history of what we've done as
software engineers and product folks
and bringing that into the model and
integrating that into your application
yeah what do you think about that yeah
no i it's absolutely something i think
needs
is needs to happen right i think people
need to uh
p people need to start taking a lot of
the things that's painful about machine
learning like the performance testing
the regression testing figuring out you
know what the limits are and all that
stuff
and automate it away like we've done
that we've done that with regular app
deployment
like we need to do it in machine
learning now because that's the thing
that's going to start to
let us move faster it's also going to
let us start to put controls and rigor
around the testing
right rather than relying on somebody
manually rigging up a test we're going
to be able to make it a piece of the
pipeline and it's just going to happen
another thing to talk about that that we
that this model sort of highlights is
this concept of localized training and
one of the things that
this is really where kubeflow shines
this is the thing that kubeflow is
awesome at
um so one of the things that that's
super important is when we look at the
cloud right you're going to be training
against
all of your aggregate data um out out
up there but when we look at you know
when we look at certain scenarios like
uh weather forecasting it's like
maybe like rain down in africa
potentially potentially i'll bless the
model and then
hopefully we can get it going yeah uh
the uh but but it's important right
there's going to be regional
differentiation there's going to be
different scenarios there's going to be
different conditions at the edge
and you might want to like tune a model
at the edge
right in in certain scenarios to fit
this case so a classic
i'm obviously i spend my time in retail
a very classic use case of this is
demand forecasting in stores
it's very easy to forecast demand uh on
an e-commerce site
uh because it's all coming through one
channel right
when i look at a store a store in
california versus a store in florida
versus a store in
uh in in maine versus a store in texas
all going to have different demand and
supply
costs so if we if we start to optimize
the supply chain and make those
predictions
we probably want to start training on on
all of our aggregate order data across
all of all of our stores
figure that out then we deploy it
locally to the store
and train against the transaction log
that that's coming in from everything
that everyone's buying
and that localizes it because we might
get bad predictions if we're looking at
the whole store because all
all of our transactions aren't
necessarily representative of what's
going on in each individual store
yeah it's that continuous learning piece
you know and
you know taking the localization factor
to it right like a majority of the
models like we used a
an an object a neural network
for animals that have four classes and
that's where we started coco from
and we transition that to to learn the
alphabet same type of thing right in
store
you know you you have different
parameters like you can tweak down at
that level but the base is always the
same
yep yep yep you're training on there and
then just you're executing another
set of training uh down at the edge
the last piece i think is one of the
most important factors as we think about
the maturity of of models in the
commercialization space
so how do you get a model to be better
how do you take it to the next level how
do you
elevate it from an mvp to a
version 2.0 we like to talk about
models in ai going from an
infancy state to a reasoning state and
then ultimately moving to a decisioning
state so that
we can augment the human element so that
we can help the human get better
and ultimately make those decisions on
their behalf with a high degree of
certainty
different businesses have different risk
thresholds and tolerances
but you know in our experience we don't
see those models kind of move forward
without taking this feedback loop in or
additional data
to adjust in the marketplace so this is
a really important component
as you think about your architecture and
you think about your deployment of
models
is how are you capturing the customer
sentiment how are you ensuring that
you know what you intend to happen is
happening
you know compliance and regulation
learning about how did you arrive at
a particular conclusion and what would
you do next time when you're there
so it's a really important event and
making that loop back into the cloud
where you're actually feeding that event
data back into your training set
yeah 100 and and even then this also
this also feeds the automation more
right uh once we build the model and we
have that object and that artifact we
you know we might make tweaks to it we
might change little things for
performance reasons
lots of little things like that but
really the thing we're going to be
constantly
doing is training it and training it
again and training it again and training
it again so if you build this pipeline
like this you're able to automate all of
that stuff away
so now your high value hard to find
hard to hire data scientists and machine
learning experts
are able to keep going and working on
new stuff rather than having to continue
to maintain
a model over and over and over again by
hand right
so this is this is i mean it's very much
reflective of the
changes we've seen in the industry uh to
this point especially as we look at app
development and kind of the
the the the way that space has evolved
over the past five or six years
uh and bringing that now that same sort
of rigor
and and decision to machine learning
yeah no that's great well you know uh
thanks for uh allowing us to have the
opportunity to come up here and talk to
you hopefully
um you guys have walked away with a
little bit more insight and knowledge as
you kind of
wind on your time at next and uh really
appreciate it and if you have any
questions yeah we're offering for
questions we've got we've got we've got
about 15 or so minutes left it looks
like and uh
we're happy to take any questions you
might have
[Music]
you